[Musique]
ça va j'ai juste un peu mon ventre je
crois que tu es enceinte atteindre la
carte
c'est le cas aussi mais les papiers à
tenir la corde rageant
il n'est pas là il en voyage on va pas
trouver une solution
ça tient premiers veulent bien la
prendre en charge 100 a déclaré à la
police tout de suite faudra quitter
l'hôpital juste après l'accouchement
c'est compliqué mais jusqu'à demain des
outils pour apporter les papiers du plat
tu connais mon super redressement
des parents sont anéantis tu les as lui
n'y est nulle
jégo l'oublier
levac et lac léman le relire tusk la
dernière fois les juges s'il vous plaît
vous allez faire quelque chose
j'avais
[Musique]
force et le courage
ce collectif jim albaugh
[Musique]